your character loves amusement parks and
and and there's a scene I think that you
shot at Magic Man yes yeah is that right
we go to Magic Mountain we shot there
for a couple days is the greatest man
they let us use the rides the whole time
they were very nice to us and are you a
fan of a music My yes I bring my kids to
amusement parks all the time so I try
not to do the thing where you cut the
line - celebrity cut the line thing but
anyways I go to Disneyland this is a
little while ago I take him to
Disneyland me my wife and the two kids
go to Disneyland well you wait on line
it's a long line right yeah a couple
hours worth of a line and we went to the
Haunted Mansion which is a great right
so where they were waiting the whole
time we get to the front and then
there's like there's four of us and it
can only get three on there my wife and
the two little kids and I'm like what I
can't go with you so I waited all this
time I can't and I end up sitting next
to another guy who couldn't go with his
family he was from kick so here you're
just saying with a random guy you don't
know just a big dude from Kansas City me
and him and we're sitting next to each
other and we're like man that's weird
and he goes should we take a nap I said
yeah for sure he was sitting a line for
three hours yeah why you're tired I'm
tired so we fall asleep on the haunted
mansion we wake up you know how there is
a ghost that isn't them when you look in
the mirror there's a ghost in between
you yeah so anyways we both wake up in
this ghost is giving us both hands yeah
that's nice
it's alright whoa whoa what's going on
in the ghost ghost that's what being
such good day oh that's right that's a
nice coat
you